il improvise un entraînement militaire
dans une décharge aux abords de le vif
ces hommes ont entre 16 et 68 ans ce
sont tous des volontaires prêts à
prendre les armes face à l'envahisseur
russes
parmi eux romane un ancien soldat
ukrainien
habitué des terrains de guerre
j'ai combattu à l'est de l'ukraine en
tant que volontaire mais après avoir été
blessé j'ai été démobilisé ma santé ne
me permet plus d'être soldat mais j'ai
pris la décision de partager mon
expérience je ne leur apprend pas à tuer
mais à survivre lors des combats nalchik
survivre en temps de guerre protéger
leur nation c'est ce qui unit ces
volontaires d'ukrainiens beaucoup n'ont
jamais manier une arme mais sont
aujourd'hui déterminé
c'est absolument nécessaire pour nous
tous de se défendre quand on voit ce qui
se passe
n'a aucune pitié pour nous il est en
train de nous détruire
à quelques encablures de là vitaly et sa
bande fabrique des obstacles antichar
dans leur atelier
d'hérisson tchèque comme il est surnommé
si pesant une centaine de kilos chacun
qui sont expédiés par tous en ukraine
j'avais du matériel que je devais
utiliser dans la construction je
construisais maison nous avons fait un
post sur facebook instagram les amis ont
commencé à reposter beaucoup de gens ont
proposé leur aide est apportée du métal
et des matériaux
la résistance s'organise dans cette
ville de l'ouest ukrainien devenu un
refuge ceux qui ne sont pas recrutés par
l'armée pour aller au front se déploie
sur les barrages à l'entrée de la ville